in 15 seconds can you describe the
technical premise behind your latest
film last call last call is a feature
film shot in real time so single take no
edits but also split screen so there's
two camera crews shooting simultaneously
that when put together in the Edit make
up the entire film and is this a style
you've tried before I have done not
suppose I have a few split screen music
videos but not real time I have done a
single take 20 minutes short film and I
worked with blum house the horror kings
to do a sort of war the world style film
that was done live on a cell phone so
streamed live no edits because it was
truly live there's no way to do it again
that ran about 20 22 minutes and was the
short film that we did right before
Halloween a few years ago and then a
bunch of single take music videos but
dealing with three to five minutes at a
time maximum what other films have you
seen in the style have you seen other
directors I mean the one that everybody
knows from back in the day is rope
Alfred Hitchcock and although a roll of
film can only run for 10 minutes what
they did was they they hid the edits
perfectly so it feels like a seamless
take Birdman was shot the same way were
they they hide they hide the edits but
but it keeps that real-time sort of
flavor to it Victoria that's on Netflix
right now is one of my favorites from a
few years ago that that one's math it's
over two hours long it's very complex
moving all over a German city time code
that Mike Vegas made was split four ways
and then with sort of a loose script and
improv and was just fascinating to watch
the experimental films my favorite song
I've been long obsessed with making one
of these myself it's just been a matter
of finding the right story that would
work what are some of the hidden
challenges that the audience doesn't see
but from a texture from it sorry
technical aspect our our film we show us
the strip down the crew as much as
humanly possible so traditionally you
have a separate person pulling focus for
the camera you have a camera assistant
for us we had the camera operator was
their own focus puller we used the new
tilda max forget the nucleus em but
their their handle grips for for a
shoulder mount that have the the focus
wheel in them so they they had to pull
their own focus be their own assistant
there just wasn't room to get in and out
of vehicles move around small apartment
spaces up and down stairs and also try
to minimize the amount of noise of
footsteps of it we really wanted to not
have to do any ADR for the actors ADR is
when they replace the dialogue it tends
to be always noticeable and never never
the right emotion we have a very
emotionally heavy film in that respect
our sound guys weren't able to use boom
mics because again there'd be too many
shadows on walls or catching it in the
frame we're trying to but the camera is
constantly moving the actors are
constantly moving in and out of cars
elevators it just wouldn't be practical
so our sound guys were only able to use
like lapel mics lav mics and what we did
was we doubled up the mics we had two
mics on each actor and that way of one
went how we would hope that the other
one was there if it became untaped and
fell down into their pant leg hopefully
we'd have another option and we actually
recorded them both just one slightly
louder one slightly quieter just in case
somebody screamed it wouldn't peak but
if they were to quietly they were
whispering we would have it on the other
mic so our sound team had the challenge
and then when it comes into
post-production it's the you know when
you color corrective film or want to
reframe anything usually if you're doing
a shot by shot it's easy to just zoom in
for that 10 seconds or color correct
shot by shot but in real time it meant
key framing which means you know picking
multiple points which by the end of it
we have hundreds if not thousands of
making minor adjustments so the camera
turns from a doorway into a darker area
and we need to brighten it up a little
bit so that you know sort of all those
color levels and sound levels are just
constantly in flux here at the whole
movie that aren't noticeable to the to
the eye
but definitely play a huge part in
making the film look as good as it can
and you edit all of your own films I do
yeah so you edit last call this was my
favorite one to edit because I didn't
have to add it anything yeah it really
truly was two two takes put side by side
so
I'm credited as the editor but it means
it means reframing so if there's a shot
where the character of Scott and Beth
are on the phone and he's maybe zoomed
the work the cameras closer to him
I would I would reframe and zoom her
shot at it but just trying to make
moments with it where the two shots
could be parallel we're just trying to
find the the best beautiful balance
between the two sides of the story but
also our although it's split screen the
the split screen changes in the film so
sometimes it's a horizontal split screen
which we did for sort of the emotional
core of the story the idea is that
that's when they're not emotionally
connected or even actually connected
over the telephone and then the bar will
rotate at times and go vertical so that
there that's when they are connected so
that the perspective of the film also
changes throughout so that involved us
in posts you know adding those rotations
in and then also moving the images at
the same time just to have the best way
as it changes from split to find the
best way to present them together so how
is that on the timeline I forgive me I'd
like so you're dragging in both cameras
and and then they're like layered on top
or like how does that yeah just just
track one is Beth sidetracked to a Scott
side and then essentially pulling a 50%
wipe or or transition over top of it so
that we only see half half of the image
and then move moving his side too you
know we what we did when we shot it was
we put lying with drew lines on the
monitor so that our you know both camera
operators could see where perfect center
was for when it was a vertical split so
they're actually shooting more on the
left and more on the right so that we
had an ability to to have some extra
room to move but they also had the lines
to the center so they knew where to put
the actors all the time no matter how
they were filming if it was from this to
this they knew that they could slightly
move and try to just do a very smooth
camera move it was all handheld and then
just put them between if they were in
those guidelines they it would work out
perfect in the Edit so no cuts no
dissolves nothing just just in the
credits at the end yeah the movie the
movie opens from a hard black after a
production company logo and then
cut so hard black before the credits so
Gavin you're directing the movie there's
two screens two locations there's one
Gavin how does that work
the intention was we would treat it like
a play once a play starts the director
sits in the audience there's nothing
else they can do all of the directing
all of the prep all the lighting cue
changes and everything is done in in the
rehearsal process or between days of
performance so I was going to yell
action and waits the 7890 or 780 minutes
and I would not be able to make any
adjustments for the next take until I
watched what was shot each day due to
some sort unforeseen circumstances I
ended up camera for any one of the sides
so as well as directing my camera our DP
SEF Wessel SC's did the one side I did
the other side and which was helpful
because the take that we use there are a
few minor mistakes the audience will
never know but it's a moment where you
know the actor could have wanted to cut
and I was at least able to shout from
behind the camera don't stop fix it keep
going
remove that audio and in post but so I
was able to make sort of minor
adjustments on my side of the screen but
the other side I was completely blind to
again shooting a micro budget the ideal
way would be I'd be sat in a production
van somewhere with the world's strongest
wireless video feeds coming in so I
could monitor both sides but just to do
the nature of our budget sort of scrappy
approach to making indie film I just had
to sit it out and hope that it went well
until until I could watch it so our
process was we shot it for four nights
so we were going to shoot twice per
night for four nights and have eight
takes that we would have to pick one of
those eight to be the movie we ended up
with five full tanks and a few disasters
oh so you are replaying the scene each
time like you're not doing new takes in
the four days or whatever you're doing
you're doing the movie over again to see
which version you like no no we was film
the entire
movie twice per night for four nights so
we we our intention was to run the
entire film if you think like a stage
play they had a seven o'clock
performance in a 10 o'clock performance
we would do two times for a night for
four nights yeah so eight runs and then
choose from the eight runs yes yeah
interesting and so your initial plan was
to be is off off you know in another
location but then you became one of the
camera operators I joked that I was just
gonna go have a whiskey or maybe take a
take a sleeping pill and just wait it
out instead of like nervously pacing for
the entire time but yeah so I was not
going to camera off but it became
necessary and with my background in
shooting documentaries and concert
footage and being my own cinematographer
for many many music videos and short
films I didn't think I was gonna be able
to do it I thought I was gonna give it
one attempt that we'd have to scrape
together some more money and fly someone
in from Los Angeles but I did I did the
first run everybody I did I did too good
of a job I should have done a less good
job so I didn't have to so me at the the
most out of shape I've ever been
something had to strap this 50-pound
camera on my shoulder and nail perfect
focus for eight takes and how far are
these locations apart we really lucked
out when we were originally discussing
the film we had we're actually gonna use
a call center it wasn't gonna be a
college and it was gonna be a suicide
hotline there's gonna be like a
telemarketing center that the character
Beth was a janitor at and that was a
good seven to eight miles away from
where where the apartments and the bar
location was but then when the college
came on board st. Clair collagen in
Windsor the locations are actually only
about two city blocks from from each
other so anytime she's outside of the
college if the camera pointed up you
could see the 17 story apartment
building that he's in like if you've
been on the balcony at the same time she
was outside you may have even seen him
in the distance with a trained eye so
that made production a little easier
because at the end of every take or
during rehearsal it was only a block or
so to go we had to drive eight miles
every time we had to do something or
new battery or or meet for a lunch break
it would have added it was sort of just
extrapolated the amount of time that we
needed we probably would have had to
find money and have more days of
rehearsal and in more time so we were
very you know it's it's just honestly
this project came together with so
little production trouble we're
considering the the tasks we were trying
to accomplish everything just started to
fall in the places like it so we knew
that Windsor was the right choice to
film in we picked the right crew and the
right people to make it happen because
the even though the process of making
the film was not easy the elements that
normally cause production so many so
many problems in terms of finding
perfect locations and then space and
then for the right price and all the
other aspects of it fell fell in line
fairly easy are you sharing monitor from
one locations footage with the other
location or no because you're doing
these long takes when you get back then
you reassess it yeah completely blind
and not until we what we would do is we
shot all of our rehearsals we had 10
days of rehearsal which was performance
rehearsal actor rehearsal the first
three days four days we were not in the
same location like what we do is we
would have both Sarah and David the
actors in the apartment David there
Scott's apartment so she would just sit
in another room in the apartment and
read lines over the phone it was just
easier to give notes and make changes
and then eventually we got comfortable
was splitting into the two location so
once we were there we would record every
rehearsal and just instead of recording
we shot the movie at 8 K on the red the
red helium but we decided we shot it
with the rehearsals at 1080p
because it was just easy at the end of
every night to put all of the rehearsal
takes into a computer and just just
roughly frame the the split so everybody
watched the rehearsals day in and day I
would like or I guess every night and
you know our DP could say that lights a
little too bright I should change this
let's try to make the cameras line up
here better when we get to this moment
when they're talking and so we sort of
use it like it like the way I would say
like the way a coach would use a game
tape from a football game to analyze the
mistakes or things they can improve or
we're tight performance or maybe a band
you know
watch back their own concert what did
you say I look silly when you do that or
that pyrotechnic didn't go off let's
make sure we fix that sort treated like
again all I needed was the the thing to
draw the screen you know that circle
circle players and it would have been a
true game tape how are you dealing with
lighting especially if you're moving and
if you're having people you know physics
yeah one thing so as well as the camera
operators having to be their own focused
pullers they also had an iris control so
they're moving safe from the street was
a little brighter than the bar they've
got to close the iris but do it do it
out of speed a very gentle speed so that
we don't really notice that some of that
we just tweak in post-production and
color to correct everything out on the
streets is just available light whenever
street light was there the bar was
mostly practical but augmented was in
film light so we would have to install
everything hide all the cables because
you know we are filming every location
360 degrees so there's nowhere to hide a
stand or leave a cable visible the
college the overhead lights are
practical but we did wrap them in a
different color gel just to give a bit
moody or moody or tone than just sort of
a hot light that you get from
fluorescence everything else in the
college is quasar tubes which has become
super popular kind of look like LED
tubes you can change the color on them
you see them in movies all the time now
because you can set them up as a
practical lamp
they look great as like under lights in
a kitchen counter or in the wall of an
office or anything kind of sci-fi there
they're great so we use those in the
computer lab or we small quasars to
accent so you say like an exit sign in a
classroom that she's cleaning just to
give it a bit more read and make it a
bit more ominous and then the apartment
that Scott's in it's mostly practical
it's changing a 60 watt bulb to a
hundred watt bulb like putting a light
in the fridge when he if he's gonna open
it that there's a little different I'm
light over the stove there were a few
lights out on the on the balcony when
he's out there that aren't that are
hidden Bernard that her film lights but
the majority of that set was just done
all all practical so there may be a
filmmaker watching right now who's
inspired by the film or the
yeah what advice would you give them
what are some of the biggest pitfalls to
making a film in this style hmm
ample rehearsal time if you're gonna
make something in real time it really
all comes into the planning all film is
pre-production to make it go well I just
think you have to a lot more time before
you roll roll camera in order to make
sure that every little detail is right
it is a it's like learning dance
choreography for the camera operators
and the technical crew and the actors to
a sentence there's just so much to
remember where you can't say oh I mess
it up let's just go back to ones and
start again the more times you do that
if you're 40 minutes into a 70 minute
take and you have to start over it's
it's it's cost a lot of money and a lot
of time to continue to do that so you
really want to put as much prep into it
as humanly possible I think the other
thing to consider too is even in like a
four minute single take music video
would have most were like that's kind of
boring for 20 seconds you know you you
have to find a way that if you're gonna
do a film with no edits how do you keep
it interesting like what's the story it
can't just be a gimmick you can't just
be we did it in a single tape because
the first question is why you have to
justify why you're using that format and
that goes the same for any any style of
filmmaking why are you using handheld
why are you doing everything on a
Steadicam like you have to you have to
know why you're doing things what the
camera motivation is what story do you
possibly have to tell that doesn't
require cuts or keeps that immediacy and
that that sort of that would that was
our goal to make a film that would
always feel immediate always feel
tension you know that phone call and as
this man's life might end so putting
that tension we thought the easiest
because every time you cut or have a
fade in and fade out to later you get a
tension relief so you probably want to
be telling a story that did you know
undeniably cannot break the tension in
order to tell something in real time and
then study study the masters go watch
timecode go watch Victoria you know make
sure you really consider even even our
cinematographer Seth you know he's
established cinematographer the first
thing he did was reach out to the the DP
of Victoria and just said how how did
you do this how did you do that and he
wrote back he was very kind
I don't have time to answer every
individual question I get asked this a
lot but I've put together this FAQ that
sort of like runs the gamut of questions
you could probably ask if there's
nothing there's anything after that you
know please please reach out so ya ask
people who have been there before
because most people are excited to share
their knowledge in this industry
especially if it's something that's in a
rare format or rare style you know I
could say positively the people that
gave me help and advice on how to do it
I'd be more than happy to pass it on so
that's it you do your research figure
out why you want to tell the story that
way don't make it just a gimmick you
know have have something real to say was
it the last version of shooting like the
last day that ended up making it in the
film or no it was day three or four the
first take so we shot this this first
take that night everybody felt amazing
about it we knew there were two little
mistakes in it but we knew that we could
like work the mistakes into the story we
found it was basically two times that
Scotch tries to use the phone to call
but actually miss dialed and got a wrong
number so you just have to hang up the
phone we're like well we'll just we'll
add in like you've reached stone so
mechanics we're not open until the
morning and so we can fix that if
everything else but everybody felt so
positive about it we said instead of
exhausting ourselves going again tonight
let's let's stop let's all go home we're
exhausted at this point through
rehearsal and said the camera guys get a
break everyone gets a break let's just
come back tomorrow and try to like go
for broke and do one bigger and better
knowing that we can live with this being
the take so the next day and the fourth
day we did our last take which was our
fifth take overall we got one and it was
really good but ultimately we we did
come back to the one that we all knew in
our guts would would be the take and
that was the very first one it was they
know it was the first take of Dave story
titles take four five yeah what was the
emotion like when even though you did
one last take he went home rested but
knowing that this could this one looked
really good even though there were two
little minor things
who knows that pure relief you know we
were getting we were on our second last
day where it's like the money runs out
tomorrow we can't come back we lose some
of our crew flights are booked for
people to fly back to Los Angeles
like it's do or die and it there there
definitely was a sense of I don't know
we're gonna get this we always knew that
going in that you know it's experimental
this might not work out we had to tell
our investors you know we've this might
not happen you know so that's part of
what you have to understand and
investing in an experimental film we
might have to do some cuts in there to
mix tapes together and just you know not
make a real-time movie anymore but when
we got it it was it was interesting
because sometimes it came down to like
the can the technical would be perfect
but one of the two actors would be like
I was I know I just know it wasn't my
best take but the other actor would have
had an amazing tape but then you have
you have this unbalance of characters
that wouldn't work and just something
would that take when we're finished
everybody knew it was it was great so it
was a lot of celebrating but also
nervousness because it's like okay well
we got to come back tomorrow I try to
like we know there's things that don't
work here it's got to be it's got to be
perfect but it's it's relief and I felt
that many times doing single taking
music videos generally and indie music
videos or any music videos now you get
one day so if you're doing single take
you don't often have a day at rehearsal
even budget wise you show up that day
you've got 12 hours to build it prep it
design it shoot it and have it done so
you usually get to around an hour 10
hour 11 being like why why do I keep
doing these single day things like just
to be so much easier if we cut so I
think like anything when it comes down
to like it's it's like the winning point
terrible sports analogies but it's like
if you only got so much time on the shot
clock to get that final you know that
final goal that final couple points to
win the game it really comes down to
that pressure like if you're that if
you're that kicker and the Super Bowl
that's gonna make or break the Super
Bowl rings you you the minute you kick
that goal through it's nothing but
relief so then you really didn't have a
rough cut once you finish sort of
piecing together different parts it was
basically just
few things and it was done yeah it was I
mean the reframing took a while the
color grading took a while but did put a
rough cut together it was like same same
day essentially like tape temp some some
music in and again our audio tracks it's
just one audio or two audio tracks from
each microphone so four audio tracks but
it's all one long continuous real-time
so to sync those up was was nothing so
there's immediately a rough cut
we got accepted to our first Film
Festival off of a rough cut before a
composer had done the music because it
he you know although he scored the movie
live like recorded in life he took the
time to write it and we talked about
where the music would go and get all the
sheet music prepped for the musicians
and whatnot yeah it's very interesting
to like walk away from movie not then
have that like the next few months of my
life or sitting in this dark room
staring endlessly at these four seconds
30-second clips trying to put a movie
together
you